fue la primera gran ciudad ucraniana en
caer en manos de las tropas rusas apenas
el días después del inicio de la
invasión ahora prácticamente rodeada por
las fuerzas ucranianas gerson podría ver
cómo se decide su destino en las
próximas semanas su administración
prorrusa dijo el domingo que la ciudad
quedó sin servicios de agua o luz
después que ataque ucranianos
destruyeran las líneas eléctricas esto
después de una serie de llamados por
parte de Moscú para la evacuación de
civiles en momentos en los que la urbe
se prepara para un inminente ataque
ucraniano
urgimos a los residentes que abandonen
la orilla derecha de la ciudad de jerson
y crucen hacia la izquierda
el fin de semana se reportaron robos
generalizados en la ciudad con soldados
rusos llevándose autos botes y otros
vehículos esto generó especulaciones de
que las fuerzas de Moscú podrían estar
preparándose para abandonar la ciudad
pero muchos combatientes ucranianos
temen que pueda tratarse de una trampa
rusa y prometieron no de la guardia
los rusos están usando estas tácticas
para engañarnos
desde la línea de frente vemos que el
enemigo está fortaleciendo sus
posiciones están trayendo nuevos
conscriptos recién movilizados podemos
sentir la diferencia han comenzado a
actuar de manera distinta
el sábado Vladimir Putin firmó una nueva
ley que permite a los ciudadanos con
condenas criminales listarse en las
fuerzas armadas esto después de que el
kremlin anunciara que ya había cumplido
con su objetivo de reclutar a 300.000
soldados adicionales para luchar en
Ucrania